the scientific worldview more than other  representations has flattered us into  believing that we can comprehend and  therefore control Ultimate Reality it is  the pretense of the mad scientist in the  laboratory and the serpent in the Garden  of Eden the lie that we shall be as gods  in reality that appeal to our pride has  brought with its fun technological  trinkets overwhelming disenchantment and  confusion about who we are about what we  are for about what is a man about what  is a woman the scientistic Liberals call  us ignorant we are we are ignorant  though perhaps not quite so ignorant as  they if at least we know it and can  admit it they call us anti-science fine  by me  it is good to see that the Earth  revolves around the Sun it is better to  see the love that moves the sun and the  other stars